today on the matt welsh show many people
in this country seem to think that if
the result of the presidential election
isn't what they want it to be it'll be
the end of life as they know it
everything's over this is why cities
have to brace for rioting if trump wins
because people are
way too emotionally invested in
presidential
politics so today i'm gonna try to
inject a little bit of sanity into this
picture if i can also five headlines
including trump
picking up another endorsement from a
prominent rapper is this an aberration
uh just a sideshow or is it a sign that
trump will do better
than the polls predict also your daily
cancellation and much more
on the way but we begin here you you
remember yesterday on the show i played
the sad and disturbing but we have to
admit kind of hilarious
video of a woman crying in her bathtub
because of amy coney barrett's
confirmation this has become
a noted genre on social media especially
tick tock where people
usually women let's be honest have
public meltdowns over
political events usually events having
to do with president trump and things
that trump has done
this goes all the way back to trump's
election um
let's hope we can say his first election
when we all remember there was panicking
and hyperventilating and people on their
knees
screaming at the sky they haven't
stopped screaming four years later they
haven't stopped
and now of course we're hearing that if
trump wins again
it'll be the end of all things the end
of america the establishment of a new
dictatorship
if trump wins the election it'll be our
last election it's not just crying women
in bathtub saying this either a lincoln
project i had released
this week made the same claim though i'm
pretty sure that the lincoln project is
run by crying women in bathtubs
can't be can't be positive though now in
any case the hysterics have reached a
fever pitch
and they'll go nuclear we all know if
trump does pull out the win
stores in many cities have already
started boarding up their windows the
national guard has been put on standby
this is all being done we should note in
anticipation of a possible trump win
nobody's worried about rioting if biden
wins unless it's celebratory writing
from democrats
so that should tell you something right
there i would think but when i look
at all of this i see the symptom of a
particularly modern disease that we
many of us anyway pin all of our hopes
and dreams and fears
on the results of political elections
especially national elections especially
presidential elections
leaving us vulnerable to mental collapse
if the results don't go our way
which they're guaranteed to not go our
way at least some of the time probably
half of the time
if you look at statistical averages over
the last 30 years or so
so this is simply irrational now
i want to be clear about something
because i know i'll be accused of this
i am not saying that the election
doesn't matter or that it's not
important or that elections don't have
consequences sometimes quite serious
consequences
i'm not telling you that you shouldn't
vote none of that is my point
my point is that our emphasis on
and focus on national politics
especially presidential politics
is way out of balance out of focus out
of proportion
my point is that presidential elections
matter
they don't matter as much as many people
in this country seem to think
people people these days you know brace
for the results of elections especially
this coming election
like their very lives depend on it like
they'll cease to exist if it doesn't go
their way
like the country will cease to exist and
that's what's been said about
every single presidential election in my
lifetime if so and so wins it'll be the
end of america
this is the end i've heard that every
four
years from my entire life
and yet here we are sure you could argue
that america
in a certain sense has has ceased to
exist
has been fundamentally transformed in a
way as to be an entirely different thing
now than what it was before
i'm sympathetic to that view but even
then the reason for that transformation
or
mutation or degradation however you want
to put it
has very little to do with who has been
president and a lot more to do with
cultural influences that are much closer
to home case in point
there have been three republican
republican administrations in my life
four if you want to count my first two
years under reagan
there have been two democrat
administrations
if we're focused just on presidential
politics you would think that we'd be in
a cultural stalemate at least or even
that conservatism has been gaining
ground winning
that's not the case the culture has
marched precipitously to the left
regardless of who happens to be in the
white house and the trend has not been
slowed much less reversed under trump
this is part of what makes the leftist
panicking about trump so absurd whether
he wins or not if you're on the left
you still have the culture you have
academia the media hollywood the
corporations everything
you have everything what are you worried
about exactly
this desperate and overwrought focus on
presidential politics
is of course in part thanks to 24-hour
cable news and the internet
people can spend all day following the
exploits of the president
and other politicians thinking about
them watching them listening to them
in ages past the average person may have
gone their whole lives
never seeing or hearing the president or
any
national politician the most they could
do is read a story in their local
newspaper
if the president gave a speech they'd
read the text of it maybe with none of
the theatrics none of the
cable news punditry attached if there
was a really significant scandal they'd
hear about it days or weeks later if at
all
not five seconds after it surfaced and
they wouldn't live
every single day hearing about it
immersed in it
the less significant scandals they may
have never heard about
and they were better for it i think
so what did the people in these times
before tv and the internet do
what do they focus on well i don't know
but i imagine they were focused first on
their families their communities
because that's the only place they could
focus
and the great thing the advantage of
that is that you can actually on your
own
affect immediate lasting and important
change in your own family
and in your own community that's the
thing you have the most control over
that's the area in which problems can
most readily be fixed
by you and that's still the case now
even as our attention is elsewhere we
may be more
intellectually invested in national
politics and more aware of it but its
immediate effect on our lives and our
immediate ability to change it
is about what it always was not
non-existent but also not nearly as
great as we assume
and it's still true now that our
families our communities should be our
first priorities
consider the common dynamic in homes
across america of a parent
on his phone arguing with strangers on
social media about stuff the president
is doing
insisting that the president's actions
are hurting his family
while his child is right there in the
room with him
being neglected he can help his family
and his child much more by putting down
the damn phone
looking at his kid having a conversation
maybe going out to play catch
or doing anything else instead he seeks
to defend and fight for his family by
fighting with a stranger a hundred miles
away about political events a thousand
miles away
this is a scene that i'm afraid to say
has simple something similar to that has
played out my own house many times more
times i'd like to admit
we all do it it's a feature of modern
life but not a good feature
and i think the breakdown of the family
is propelling the shift even more it's
not just technology
you know if you don't have a family to
care for or be cared by
be cared about by you you look for
solace and meaning and
purpose and influence elsewhere many
people find it in politics elections
government
arguably the worst possible places to
find a surrogate
surrogate family so again i'm not saying
that the election doesn't matter that it
isn't important that you shouldn't vote
not saying any of that it is important
and as long as you're an informed
intelligent competent adult you should
vote if you're not you shouldn't
let's keep things in perspective is all
i suggest
and when people ask me as they have many
times
what will you do if trump loses how will
you respond
what will you do next my answer is this
i'll wake up the next morning eat
breakfast
put on my shoes go about my day
i will not spontaneously combust if the
presidential election goes differently
than i wanted to
i'm not gonna break down in tears in the
middle of the street
not gonna scream at the sky not gonna
panic
i may not be happy i'll probably be
angry
but also i'll be okay
i'll be alive and so will you
and that's something that's worth
keeping in mind i think let's get to our
five headlines
you know hard to believe it but the
holidays are coming up already again uh
we're coming up fast upon it i'm already
seeing the christmas decorations hearing
the christmas music which is fine with
me by the way i don't understand people
complain
about hearing christmas music too early
i mean it's never too early to christmas
music in my opinion but anyway
that's beside the point with all this
coming up really fast you're thinking
about you know what kind of gift can you
get your family well let me suggest the
perfect gift for
any family or any person is a family
portrait that you can get from paint
your life
if you want to give a truly meaningful
gift you've gotta try paintyourlife.com
this is a this is a guaranteed to be a
hit absolute
guarantee you get a professional
hand-painted portrait created from any
photo
at a truly affordable price you can send
any picture yourself your children your
family a special place a cherished pet
if you give it a gift you probably don't
don't want it to be a portrait of
yourself
um although that would be an interesting
thing
but whatever you want to do you can send
it in and or you can combine a bunch of
other stuff to make one one painting
with paint your life's compilation
portraits you can bring together family
members who never had a chance to meet
or you can create a portrait of the
whole family without the need for
everyone to be there for the family
photo
choose from a team of world-class
artists and work with them until every
detail is perfect
you can order a custom-made hand-painted
portrait in less than five minutes
and uh it's a quick and easy project you
can get the hand-painted portrait back
in about three weeks i mean that's how
quick this thing
thing is and they're very responsive
i've gone through this myself
uh we were very happy with the results
i'm also very happy with the process
where
you know any feedback any changes you
want to make they're happy to do it at
paintyourlife.com
plea there's no risk if you don't love
the final painting
your money is refunded it's guaranteed
and right now it's a limited time offer
get 20 off your painting that's right 20
off
and free shipping to get this special
offer text the word matt to 64 000
that's matt
to 64 000 text matt matt to 64 000 paint
your life
celebrate the moments that matter most
all right number one speaking of
politics let's get into it in political
news lil wayne has uh
has pulled a kanye west and endorsed
trump here's the tweet from lil wayne he
says just had a great meeting with real
donald trump
besides what he's done so far with
criminal reform the platinum plan is
going to give community
the community real ownership he listened
to what we had to say today and assured
that he will that he will and can get it
done
uh so i i guess it doesn't that's not
technically a full endorsement but it's
just about and there they are given the
picture the uh
thumbs up in the photo though the the
political alliance
trump and lil wayne so lil wayne joins
of course kanye west
i want to say 50 cent but i think 50
cent rescinded his endorsement
i might be i could be wrong i didn't
care enough to read the story but
even so this is a surprising turn of
events plus the rapper lil
pump endorsed trump so trump appears to
have cornered the market
on lilles he's got lil wayne little pump
uh here's a little pumps endorsement by
the way he shot out sort of an
endorsement video that i thought was
pretty astute
uh listen to this hey all i gotta say is
trump 2020 i look like paying an extra
33 and tax for biting
sleepy joe trump 2020
yeah you know in so many words that's
basically my own argument for trump as
well
one of them anyway i'm a fan of of
politicians taking less of my money
i kind of like that myself and what you
just heard there that is
more insightful easily than any
political analysis you'll hear on cnn
um so you see this kind of stuff and
maybe it gives you hope a little bit if
you're a trump supporter
maybe there are a lot of unexpected so
far uncounted trump votes out there who
knows
there's gonna need to be if trump has a
hope of winning
i think um so i factor all this together
and i'd have to say that
right now because i always i also get
people all the time asking me for my
my prediction what's going to happen
and factoring all this looking at the
polls looking at the rally turnout the
endorsements
everything my official official election
night prediction is this
i have no damned clue not the foggiest
i really have no idea i i could talk
myself into believing that trump
wins narrowly i could talk myself into
believing that trump loses in a
landslide
i could talk myself into a tie i can
talk to myself in a lot of different
things
so so really whatever happens i will
i won't be surprised but i will be at
the same time
that's my prediction you can take that
one to the bank number
two okay crafty stuff here from nbc news
a big story allegedly
the headline how a fake persona laid the
groundwork for a hunter biden conspiracy
deluge
now it continues a 64-page document that
was later disseminated by close
associates of president
president donald trump appears to be the
work of a fake intelligence firm
so that's really all you're supposed to
read right there fake conspiracy theory
fake story hunter biden loose
associations
that's all you're supposed to do you
read the headline you move on
and you're supposed to think okay well
all the hunter biden stuff is phony
but wait a second let's read the actual
article it says one month before a
purported leak of files from hunter
biden's laptop
a fake intelligence document about him
went viral on the right-wing internet
asserting an elaborate conspiracy theory
involving president
or vice president joe biden's son and
business in china
the document a 64-page composition that
was later disseminated by close
associates of president donald trump
appears to be the work of a fake
intelligence firm called typhoon
investigations according to researchers
and public documents
the author of the document a
self-identified swiss security
analyst named art martin aspen is a
fabricated identity
according to analysis by disinformation
researchers
who also concluded that aspen's profile
picture was created with an artificial
intelligence
face generator okay
so in other words shifting through all
that
this has nothing at all to do with the
laptop this is some other
thing that they say it went viral and
right-wing
websites across right-wing social media
i'm on right-wing social media i never
saw it i don't even know what they're
talking about
so this is some other thing no one's
ever heard of
some document no one's ever heard of
from a month ago
that nbc news says it's fake for the
sake of argument let's just trust what
they're saying okay fine
it's fake who cares why is this news
no one even knew about this fake thing
nobody was talking about this thing
why are you bringing this up now well
obviously the idea here is to muddy the
waters to get people to
draw these associations between hunter
biden's story
and conspiracy theory they just want
those associations there
and so this is just all about getting
that headline out there
so that it also has the effect of of
discrediting in people's minds the
laptop story which again has nothing to
do with this thing that nbc news is
talking about
so it's a it's a clever trick put out an
unrelated story as a way of discrediting
the real story um
so that's that's all there is but you
know
this this goes to some of my frustration
with the with the hunter biden laptop
thing and i've already shared with you
my my hesitations in general
wondering you know if this is going to
resonate with the voters if the voters
will really care
i think they should care it's a big
story it matters it's a scandal okay so
this is not my assessment of what people
should think
more just just wondering about what they
do think and what they will do
um and also i've i've i've been worried
that
in the closing moments of the campaign
this might be the wrong closing argument
do we want our closing argument about
joe biden to be
about hunter biden even if it is
associated with joe
or are there more direct immediate
more important arguments about joe biden
that we ought to be making that are now
de-emphasized because of the focus on
hundred by
that's a separate thing but the other
problem is this this slow
leak strategy the people that have the
laptop rudy giuliani whoever else has
the laptop or has the information on it
they've been leaking out the stuff
slowly over the course of weeks and even
now
you still get these teases from people
in in right-wing media who say they have
the information saying this is the tip
of the iceberg there's more to come
dude we're three days away from the
election four days
what are you still teasing stuff for if
you have it put it out
i mean what's already been released is
is damning but if you're telling us this
as
it gets even worse well what are you
show it to us
now it's time to show the iceberg
my fear is that this whole strategy has
been has been handled
horribly waiting way too long to bring
up the laptop and
taking way too long to get the
information out
probably if you're gonna go this route
they should have dumped all the
information from the laptop
like two months ago before the first
debate before you already had 80 million
80 million people have already voted i
think it's up to now
and there's still information about the
laptop that they haven't told us yet
uh it's just two months ago they should
have put everything out
it gives time for people to sift through
it it gives time for it to
kind of for this narrative to take hold
for people to start second guessing
you know if you want to start getting if
you want
people to start thinking of joe biden as
a corrupt and untrustworthy politician
and i believe that he is
but that's not how most people see him
so if you want then this is a guy that's
been in the public light for 50 years
so if you want to change the way most
people see him
you need to do it in more than two weeks
you need months to do that
anyway so but part of the problem is
this slow leak approach also gives time
uh for the other side to include the
media
to do things like this to come up with a
strategy of of
you know combating it and you're giving
them time as as more information comes
out you give them time it's sort of
easier for them to ignore it or to do
things like this to distract from it
i think that would have been harder to
do if everything came out all at once in
one big avalanche
like two two months ago let's say okay
number three uh
second day of kim kardashian news in the
headlines much to my shame
she says for my birthday kanye got me
the most thoughtful gift of a lifetime a
special surprise from heaven a hologram
of my
dad it's so lifelike we watched it over
and over filled with emotion
and uh it is actually a hologram of her
deceased father
here's the hologram you're 40 and all
grown up
you look beautiful just like when you
were a little girl
i watch over you and your sisters and
brother and the kids
every day sometimes i drop hints that
i'm around
like when you hear someone make a big
peafy
or when you make a big pifi
remember when i would drive you to
school on my tiny mercedes every day
we would listen to this song together
[Music]
who was that man
i am so proud of the woman that you've
become
kimberly and all that you've
accomplished all of your hard work and
all the businesses you have built
are incredible but most impressive is
your commitment to become a lawyer
and carry on my legacy okay so that's
that's weird
um i i think get a little creepy but it
gets worse
listen to this part you married the most
most most most most genius man in the
whole world
kanye west yes kanye west
really made a hologram of his wife's
dead father
and had the hologram call him kanye the
most genius man in the world
there's got to be a word other than
narcissism for that this is several
steps above
normal narcissists are looking at that
and thinking wow
they are they are highly impressed this
is like turbo narcissism narcissism
squared narcissism the deluxe package
this is just
amazing and also pretty creepy in my
mind i i i would just
say to anyone close to me if there's any
you know
multi-millionaires close to me that are
thinking of uh
getting me a birthday gift or christmas
gift pl
please i don't want any holograms of any
dead relatives i
i never want that let me just say that
now publicly
number four andrew cuomo was on the view
yesterday and let's see how that went
governor few people uh have a better
understanding of how to manage the
pandemic
than you do wait okay st stop it there
i'm i'm i'm sorry what
he's this is like telling the dude from
fire festival
that few people have a better
understanding of event planning than he
does
this is now though if you look at it
another way it kind of makes sense
because you could say that
you need to have a firm understanding of
how to do the right thing if you want to
succeed in doing the exact
opposite of the right thing you can
argue it takes a lot of planning and
execution
literally and figuratively to do as
poorly as cuomo has done
so maybe that's what she meant i don't
know let's let's go with that though
number five finally this video that i'll
play now uh almost got itself on the
daily cancellation it was very close it
was a near tie
almost got there this is from the media
outlet now this which puts out horrible
cringy stuff all the time but this
may be worse than anything else they've
put out the title is
most americans got smaller tax refunds
in 2019
thanks to donald trump listen to this
my refund was about half of what it
normally is we were really banking on
the refund
i called my husband immediately crying
[Music]
so i went back in and i checked
everything and then i started to cry
this year i just don't have a refund
[Music]
my refund was about half of what it
normally is it used to be like four
thousand and then i got two thousand
this year
[Music]
but this year instead of getting back
the five thousand dollars right was
expecting and that she and her husband
got last year
the houston mom found they actually owed
the government money
with the birth of new daughter olivia
just three weeks ago
wright says her family was counting on a
tax refund
to cover the cost of her unpaid
maternity leave we were really banking
on the refund because we
you know we love paycheck to paycheck we
can't in a sense
save as of right now with three kids in
college the edney family is now
scrambling
last year they got a ten thousand dollar
refund but because of high property
taxes this year
they owe ten thousand dollars okay stop
stop it again
make it stop just make it stop i mean it
actually says in the video on the screen
it explains it admits that in most cases
people didn't get a refund because they
paid less in taxes
and had more money in their paychecks
yet we're still getting this
tearful sorrowful complaining video
um so why do they get less
in the refunds because refunds aren't
bonus
checks that's not what they are my god
if you got a lower refund that's a good
thing it means you paid
less in taxes it means you kept more of
your own money
a refund is just the government
returning the money it took from you
as a no interest loan it's better to not
give a no interest loan if you could
choose between giving a no interest loan
or not giving a no interest loan
financially there is no benefit
whatsoever
to the no interest loan loaning the
government money and receiving it back
with no interest there's no benefit to
you
it is better to keep your own money 100
percent
you could invest that money in a million
different ways
or spend it waste it whatever you're
going to do and that's what most people
do with their tax refunds anyway they
just wasted on on crap
um but you could do that with your
paycheck i mean it's
it's there's no advantage really no
financial advantage
now i look i understand the
psychological
advantage the psychological boon of
getting a check in the mail certainly
feels a lot better than mailing one
a refund sort of feels like it's
equivalent to
finding money in the couch cushions
right
it feels like free money but it's not
okay and intentionally trying to make it
so that you get a refund
is like purposefully stashing wads of
cash in the in the couch for the thrill
of finding it later
it's it's one thing to go oh cool five
bucks didn't realize i had this when you
pull it out of the couch questions
that's fine
but taking five dollars and putting it
under the kitchen
as an investment strategy is psychotic
and that's what people do with
withholding they they want they they
withhold more because they want the
refund
just put it in a savings account i mean
you'll get interest that was not a lot
of interest but it's more than you'll
get from the government
have you ever heard of a bank account i
hated some people all the time
they actually tell me they withhold more
so that they get a refund
have you ever heard of a bank that's
what they're for
stop giving the government money for no
reason
this is why we need i i'm not going to
go off on my uh
withholding thing again but this is why
we need to this is why we need to
abolish withholding
the whole withholding system it'll never
be abolished because it's so convenient
for god i mean it's
it's made people happy about paying
taxes tax day has turned into a happy
day for a lot of people which it
shouldn't be
but that's the dastardly strategy behind
the withholding system
all right we're going to get to our
daily cancellation in just a second but
first um
i i did want to mention one other thing
not a news item technically but just
something inspiring and beautiful to
share there's been a lot of negativity
so i wanted to share this with this is
something i haven't had a chance to
mention yet but it's from our trip to
nashville
uh over the weekend and we uh
we stopped at a hotel as i've as i've
mentioned when i was canceling pets
early
earlier in the week canceling my cat and
everyone else's cat
anyway the next morning on the way out
of the hotel i was saying to my wife
that we should go to a cracker barrel
for breakfast
and my wife for some reason somehow was
against going to cracker barrel
she was anti-cracker barrel she was
engaging in all kinds of
fake news propaganda uh in her attempts
to defame and slander
cracker barrel and then i'm not making
this up this is not photoshop
just as we're walking out and talking
about this
i look up and here's the picture here an
actual rainbow a double rainbow actually
uh
over the cracker barrel sign
look at that amazing this this really
happened this is a sign from god
angels lighting the path hallelujah he
has risen amen
how could you look at that image and and
tell me there is no god
you can't and yes we did stay at a hotel
right next door to a cracker barrel
because we're a high-class family you
understand
and it's also true that virginia has
five cracker barrels
at every highway exit so any rainbow is
bound to hit one you could say but even
so
um i still just enjoy the beauty of it
that is providence
that is also god supporting my side of
the argument
i think and by the way we still didn't
end up going to cracker barrel
of course all right um one other thing
you know
it's uh it's we're talking about
investment strategies and
bad ways to invest your money is
investing it in withholding
money for your paycheck here's a good
investment strategy gold okay
there's there's a place you could really
here's something you could do with your
money if you had more money in your
paycheck which a lot of us do
um but the problem is it's just
expensive to just go out and buy gold
so here's something new you know how the
price of gold has been skyrocketing
lately
well there's a new way to buy gold
through a company called acre acre lets
you subscribe to gold
for as little as 30 a month you pay each
month and once your gold stash reaches
the price of the gold bars
they discreetly ship acre gold to your
home acre lets you invest in physical
gold
without it coming out of your pocket all
at once so it's a lot easier that way
and with acre taking physical delivery
of your gold means it's safe
and it's sound and it's going to be in
your hands you don't have to worry about
anything acre ships your gold directly
and discreetly to your door
acre designs their gold in california
sources are gold from one of the largest
mints in switzerland
and uh they just recently introduced
their new 100 per month
subscription for their 5 grand gold bar
so that's another option you have as
well
visit getacregold.com start investing in
physical gold today
and make sure you go to this url because
acre's also giving away
a gold bar and that's an opportunity you
don't want to miss either to qualify for
the giveaway tweet or post
why you should be the recipient of this
gold bar make it creative make it funny
that will always help
and mention at get underscore acre and
if you do that you might get the free
gold bar but either way
go to get acre gold dot com slash walsh
and thank you
big thank you to acre gold for
supporting the show
let's get to our five headlines actually
i mean our daily cancellation not our
five headlines i'm cancelled too because
i don't even know what segment i'm doing
right now
but today for our daily cancellation
i'll be canceling the gentleman in this
video that i'm about to play for you not
just him also anyone with his attitude
his toxic approach to life
so this is someone called jeffrey marsh
he is a non-binary
quote unquote he says uh that's that's
what he is and he has a little bit of
scolding he wants to send your way
because
you aren't scolded enough of course he's
figured that it's been five and a half
minutes since
the last lgbt scolding session and so
it's time for another one
and here it is oh i'm aware
that because i'm non-binary i'm
confusing
to you but you're going to have to
respect
me you think that
getting it comes before respecting me
but it's the other way around you need
to
see my humanity you must respect me and
talk to me like a human being
and then maybe later you'll get it but
that's the least
important part okay first of all uh
no you're not you're not confusing to me
i mean you're wearing earrings and
makeup i understand the concept
i can't much relate to the fashion
choices but
you're not like blowing my mind by
putting on women's clothes
this is one of the things that always
gets me people these days think they've
invented some new
edgy unheard of unquantifiable category
of existence
when they're not doing anything new i
understand i'm so confusing to you you
have no idea what's going on i've opened
up your mind to new possibilities
no not really you're wearing eyeliner
and earrings
hair metal bands were doing that in the
80s so you're not breaking new ground
here
it reminds me when i was in high school
and the thing then if you wanted to
shock and confuse people
was to be a goth right back in the late
90s early 2000s
wear black lipstick fishnet stockings
and these kids would walk around
like look at me i'm shocking and unique
no you're not you just look like a hot
topic cashier you're not you're not
throwing me for a loop here
you have to try harder than that if you
want to shock me so that's the first
thing
but not really my point he also says
repeatedly you're going to have to
respect me
you must respect me respect me this is a
very common attitude people walking
around demanding respect
claiming that they're owed respect that
the world must respect them
no that's not how it works in fact
i don't have to respect you i am under
no obligation to respect you
and i don't respect you frankly until
you give me a reason to
and the reason can't be that you're
instructing me to
i need an actual reason the dictionary
defines
respect as quote a feeling of deep
admiration for someone or something
elicited by their abilities qualities or
achievements
so you think i have to have a feeling of
deep admiration for you i have to have
that
i must you think that's some sort of
essential requirement of existence that
we all have to admire you
no you egomaniac that's not how this
goes this is a concept that as i say
many people in our culture struggle to
understand
a great portion of the problems in our
country today stem from this fundamental
confusion the idea that whatever we do
however we act whoever we are the world
owes us respect no
it doesn't there is a difference between
demanding respect and
commanding respect to demand respect is
to shout impotently into the void
it is to try and conjure respect by the
sheer force of your own desire for it
but you can't you can't make people
respect you by berating and scolding
them you can make them roll their eyes
and walk away
because you're annoying them to death so
if that's what you mean by respect then
fine
but if you want admiration if you want a
deep recognition of your abilities and
achievements
you're going to have to earn it you're
going to have to command it
respect is commanded not by verbal
declaration but by a person's behavior
their poise their dignity
nobody who demands respect commands
respect
because if they commanded it they
wouldn't have to demand it
the moment someone says respect me you
know this is someone you shouldn't
respect
because they have to say it respect is a
little bit like belief
in that you know you can't run up to me
make an absurd claim without evidence
and
insist that i believe it i literally
can't believe it it's not just that i
don't want to or i have chosen not to i
can't
i don't choose to believe or not believe
something nobody says to themselves
i think i'll choose to believe this okay
there it is i believe it
no belief is a natural consequence
something that happens on its own
or doesn't happen respect is the same
way if i find you to be a ridiculous or
unimpressive or unremarkable or pitiful
or
character deficient person i can't
respect you i literally
can't even if i wanted to i couldn't
respect rises naturally out of a
recognition of someone's respectable
qualities
if you don't have those qualities or at
least if you have not provided evidence
of them to me
then that respect cannot come
you might as well demand that like a
tree start sprouting skittles or
something
you're expecting fruits from seeds you
have not planted
so what i would say to our friend
jeffrey marsh and everyone else is that
if you want the world to respect you
give it a reason to
a reason aside from the mere fact that
you wanted to
because that's not a reason and so
everyone who demands respect rather than
earning it
is canceled with all due respect
which is to say none at all
that's it for today and for the week
have a great weekend everybody
big week next week godspeed
the matte wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
our technical producer is austin stevens
edited by danny d'amico
and our audio is mixed by robin
fenderson the matt wall show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
20.
if you prefer facts over feelings aren't
offended by the brutal truth and you can
still laugh at the insanity filling our
national news cycle
well tune in to the ben shapiro show
we'll get a whole lot of that and much
more
see you there